[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur ce plateau
de la grande interview avec cette
semaine christian cambon sénateur
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères
plus précisément des affaires étrangères
de la défense et des forces armées au
sénat monsieur le président c'est bien
ça le titre bonjour d'abord absolument
bonjour merci d'être là avec pascal
actualité bien sûr qu'ils aient dominé
par tous les problèmes sanitaires les
problèmes économiques appellent quand
même des éclairages parce que tout ça
peut avoir un impact bien sûr sur la
politique étrangère
alors pour essayer de comprendre ce qui
se passe notamment de ce qui se passe en
europe mais aussi de ce qui se passe
avec les états unis ou même de ce qui se
passe avec la russie est ce que je peux
vous demander comme ça pour démarrer
c'est un peu une question de court mais
vous avez l'habitude quel est pour vous
président de la commission la place de
la france dans le monde aujourd'hui
c'est une place qui est évidemment très
importante et qui malheureusement depuis
quelques années et pas simplement ce
depuis ce ce gouvernement et ce
président mais a eu plutôt tendance à a
reculé un peu parce que d'une manière
générale nous voyons que les régimes
parlementaires démocratiques ont
peut-être un petit peu plus de mal à se
faire entendre et à user de leur
influence dans les grandes crises que
nous connaissons et qui secoue le monde
et et d'une manière générale qui mettant
en danger la paix la france est un très
grand pays nous sommes membres du
conseil de sécurité
nous sommes nous sommes dotés de
dissuasion nucléaire et
à tous ces titres nous avons un réseau
diplomatique parmi les plus importants
au monde et donc nous avons les moyens
effectivement d'user de notre influence
mais soit parce que souvent nous avons
pris des initiatives un peu solitaire
pas toujours en relation avec nos amis
européens soit parce qu'on sait parfois
aussi trompé de stratégie et bien notre
rôle est peut-être moins important que
ce que l'on souhaiterait je je je prends
la crise la plus évidente est que tout
le monde connaît kessel
du moyen-orient et de la palestine et
d'israël on voit bien que la voix de la
france est moins entendu qu'elle a pu
l'être précédemment oui alors et vous
l'avez dit cette place a été déterminée
dans le passé mais les encore par
l'importance de notre défense nationale
vous faisiez allusion à un autre à notre
potentiel nucléaire nous avons c'est
vrai une des armées les plus puissantes
dans le monde
mais vous savez que beaucoup de
responsables politiques plaident pour
réorienter les efforts budgétaires de la
france dans d'autres directions
qu'est ce que vous répondez à tous ceux
qui disent aujourd'hui que l'effort
militaire ne correspond plus à nos
besoins
eh bien je leur réponds appuyant sur ce
malheureux événement sanitaires que nous
venons de vivre
je pense en effet que les crises
géostratégique
c'est comme les crises sanitaires c'est
pas au moment où on est dedans qu'il
faut s'en préoccuper et donc plus que
jamais nous vivons dans un monde
extrêmement dangereux où les grandes
puissances mettent en avant leurs
intérêts dans ces temps où le
multilatéralisme connaît une crise est
évidente
je pense que la france se doit plus que
jamais de se doter de moyens militaires
pour sa défense pour sa sécurité
vous savez depuis 20 ans nos armées
françaises ont été littéralement éreinté
à chaque fois on leur a imposé des
efforts budgétaires des décontraction
dans les dépenses et ceci a des
conséquences au jour d'aujourd'hui qui
sont très préoccupantes
on a eu on est en train de corriger mais
enfin on a eu jusqu'à un hélicoptère sur
deux qui étaient maintenus au sol faute
d'entretien faute de pièces détachées et
donc tout ceci nuit d'une manière
générale à notre capacité de répondre
aux circonstances alors même que le
monde devient de plus en plus dangereux
de plus de plus en plus
lourdes péril le terrorisme bien
évidemment les conflits régionaux les
les luttes d'influencé entre les grandes
puissances et ceci nous oblige me
semble-t-il à faire un effort important
pour rehausser au bon niveau
nos forces armées mais alors ça sans
polémiquer cette place de la france se
situe elle dans une organisation du
monde qui a quand même était beaucoup
bouleversé depuis une vingtaine d'années
est-ce que cet effort dont vous parlez
que vous appelez de vos voeux doit
continuer de s'inscrire dans le cadre
actuel de l'otan ou alors est ce qu'on
peut imaginer d'autres alliances qui
serait par exemple plus européenne et
est ce que vous y travaillez alors je
pense effectivement que les les deux
systèmes
les deux organisations celles de l'otan
qui existait à laquelle la france adhère
bien évidemment peuvent se peuvent se
surajouter aux efforts que nous faisons
les uns et les autres et que la france
essaie de faire pour que la défense et
la sécurité européenne soient mieux
prises en compte
il ya eu de ce point de vue des appels
ont été lancés par le président de la
république et qui vont me semble-t-il
dans le bon sens parce que il faut que
la il faut que l'europe puisse bien
évidemment prendre la mesure des défis
qui sont les siennes
qui sont les siens je vais prendre un
exemple nous avons à l'heure où nous
parlons
environ nous avons deux millions un tout
petit peu plus de 2 millions d'européens
qui sont sous les drapeaux des
différentes armées européennes et nous
sommes en très grandes difficultés pour
aligner plus de cinq mille cinq cents
hommes au sahel
alors qu'une partie de notre sécurité se
joue dans cette partie du monde et donc
je vois là
cité absolue à la fois de mieux
coordonner nos efforts d'échanger sur
nos stratégies de de faire aussi des
analyses qui soit commune et d'essayer
d'y répondre
petit à petit me semble-t-il je crois
pas qu'on puisse se bascule est
brusquement vers le concept d'une armée
européenne d'une défense européenne
mais j'ai de nombreux exemples cités de
coopération qui vont dans le bon sens et
qui donne à l'europe qui font prendre à
l'europe conscience de de satde de sa
force
je pense par ailleurs que la politique
américaine les déclarations de
l'actuelle administration américaine
vont dans ce sens le président trump a
déclaré à plusieurs reprises notamment à
bruxelles dans une déclaration qui était
restée célèbre que c'était aux deux
européens de se prendre en charge de
dépenses et pour leur défense lui-même
procède à des retraits réguliers de
troupes
encore dernièrement 8000 hommes en
allemagne
eh bien je pense que la conséquence de
tout ça c'est qu'il faut que le concept
de sécurité commune en europe avance et
que nous fassions tous un effort je
pense qu on est en train de progresser
même si encore beaucoup de chemin à
accomplir sable ça veut dire que ça veut
dire même que le cadre de l'otan est
remis en cause aujourd'hui ou pas le
temps traverse une crise indiscutable on
vient de le voir avec des incidents
regrettables avec qui nous oppose à un
allié particulièrement turbulents et
inquiétant qui est la turquie
voilà vous avez vu qu'il ya quelques
semaines
un des navires de la marine nationale
turque que j'allais dire interpellé je
vais pas jusqu'au terme d'agression mais
en tous les cas interpellés dans des
conditions tout à fait inacceptables un
navire de la marine française qui
intervenait dans le cadre d'une
opération de surveillance de l'embargo
des armes en libye
nous avions nous avions une frégate qui
a été donc ciblé à trois reprises par un
radar de tir turc
on voit bien que il y à un certain
nombre de problèmes entre nous et je les
dis moi je les dis ou secrétaire général
de l'otan puisque je je suis membre de
l'assemblée parlementaire de l'otan
je pense qu'il faut que le temps parle
un tout petit peu plus de ses problèmes
intérieurs plutôt que de parler
systématiquement de des dangers que
représente la russie ou la difficulté
que l'on peut rencontrer ici ou là je
crois que il y à un approfondissement à
avoir sur les buts que poursuit le temps
le président de la république la demande
et il a utilisé des mots forts mais je
suis pas loin de penser qu'il avait
raison qu'est ce que peut faire la
france dans un cas comme ça c'est à elle
d'intervenir directement c'est à elle de
protéger directement ou c'est par le
biais de l'otan fait plus frais
normalement par le biais de l'otan ah
non maintenant c'est déjà par le biais
de l'otan il ya des conférences
régulières les mini se voit les chefs
d'état se voit il ya des sommets à
bruxelles et ailleurs
donc je pense qu'il faut déjà sur ce
sujet évoqué les balles et les vrais
problèmes
à quoi doit servir le temps contre qui
était le diriger
voilà des vrais sujets moi
personnellement dans toutes les
interventions que je fais dans ces
assemblées je demande qu'on regarde
moins à l'est nous ne sommes pas naïfs
nous savons bien que et ont pour nom
aura l'occasion d'en reparler
nous ne partageons pas toutes les mêmes
analyses avec nos amis russes mais je ne
considère pas au jour d'aujourd'hui que
la russie russie représente un danger
tel qu'il doit mobiliser la totalité des
recense de l'otan en revanche on ne
parle jamais de ce qui se passe au sud
on a beaucoup de mal à intervenir un en
sorte que l'on puisse débattre des
problèmes qui se passe au sud où le
terrorisme sous toutes ses formes doit
être combattue moi je me réjouis bien
évidemment qu'elles s'attendent de
contingents européens viennent nous
aider mais ils sont globalement petit
nombre l'allemagne participe uniquement
sur des des thèmes de logistique et nous
sommes quand même assez seul nous avons
nous-mêmes 5100 bons hommes qui sont là
et qui chaque jour se battre
courageusement ont subi du reste des
pertes lourdes est mort bien sûr près
d'une cinquantaine des blessés tout ceci
pose problème et l'otan pourrait
réfléchir
effectivement et un dispositif de
sécurisation de notre continent et je
pense qu'il faut le faire de manière un
tout petit peu plus indépendante qu'on
l'a conçu jusqu'à présent vous
considérez que le bouclier américain
régler tous les problèmes
ce n'est plus le cas et je pense qu'il
faut d'abord une prise de conscience
deuxièmement partager des analystes et
après m'être en commun un certain nombre
de moyens il ya un calendrier de
négociations de conversations prévu pour
à thuré fait évolution pour la faire
progresser ou pas il ya un calendrier
mais il est assez lent il pour l'instant
je peut pas franchement dire qu'il a
débouché sur de véritables propositions
on voit sur les dernières difficultés
que nous venons de connaître avec la
turquie
enfin voilà voilà deux alliés qui sont
membres de la même alliance et qui était
non pas au bord
au bord de la guerre mais était
véritablement dans une situation où un
incident pouvait effectivement se
produire eh bien on a dit qu'il
s'agissait d'un désaccord entre alliés
c'est plus qu'un désaccord je pense
qu'il faut ce sont des choses dont il
faut parler pour l'instant il ya la
france a demandé qu'il y ait un
calendrier de discussions
nos alliés sont d'accord sur le principe
maintenant il faut que ça se concrétise
par des résultats
quel est le prochain rendez vous
diplomatiques official normalement il ya
des sessions régulières des ministres de
la défense des ministres affaires
étrangères de l'otan il ya aussi nos
robes des conférences permanent je pense
qu'à l'automne ou à tout le moins une
initiative devrait être prise en tous
les cas c'est le souhait de la france et
c'est ce que nous mêmes au sénat nous
soutenons alors vous avez parlé de la
russie on en parle dans un instant le
temps de faire une petite pause de pub
et on se retrouve dans un quart de
seconde
[Musique]
retour sur le plateau de la grande
interview on se retrouve avec christian
cambon sénateur président de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées au céda et
nous parlions monsieur le sénateur à
l'instant de la place de la france dans
le temps nous parlions aussi du rôle
éventuel de la russie parce que c'est à
la corse est un acteur important dans
cette région qui veut jouer sa carte
bien sûr assuré son pouvoir au moyen
orient assurer son influence en europe
alors vous avez très récemment rencontré
votre homologue russe un par visiophone
j'imagine pour actualiser ce que vous
appelez l'agenda de confiance entre la
france et la russie et dans cet agenda
qui est un document assez complet assez
lourd
vous avez demandé une coopération
sécuritaire plus développés ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire d'abord que au sénat
nous considérons que le dialogue avec la
russie est un élément fondamental de la
politique extérieure de la france et que
nous nous pas nous parlementaires
nous souhaitons y apporter notre
contribution par ce que l'on appelle un
peu pompeusement la diplomatie
parlementaire mais qui est en fait la
possibilité d'échanger avec nos
collègues et de nous mettre d'essayer de
faire avant d'essayer déjà de
d'identifier les points d'accord et les
points d accord car nous en avons et
puis de dialoguer pour voir les
solutions que l'on peut faire avancer
alors nous avons mis en chantier un
travail tout à fait originale puisque
effectivement vous avez la gentillesse
de cité nous venons de publier après de
longs mois de travaux nous venons de
publier un rapport commun en français et
en russe et a été réalisée à la fois par
le conseil de la fédération de russie et
par le sénat français et qui dans le
cadre de cet agenda de
de confiance identifie si grande si
grandes thématiques sur lequel du reste
nous trouvons beaucoup de points
d'accord beaucoup de points de
coopération et puis où nous identifions
aussi nos divergences nos différences
d'analysé on sait qu'il y en a et la
moindre des choses quand on a des amis
c'est de se parler franchement et c'est
ce travail tout à fait important qui a
été fait et qui a été transmis du reste
au gouvernement au président de la
république ainsi que le président
poutine en ce qui concerne la russie et
aux différentes instances qui sont
capables d'en connaître et déjà si vous
voulez ce document a comme intérêt
d'établir un constat de tous les points
de convergence et puis des points de
divergence
quatre des points de quoi ôter des
points de convergence il ya
effectivement cette recherche commune
d'une meilleure organisation de la
sécurité en europe parce que encore une
fois il n'y a pas de crise dans le monde
et singulièrement sur nous continent qui
ne puisse se résoudre sans que la russie
soit elle-même reconnu identifiés dans
son rôle et puissent participer à des
négociations
alors pour ça il ya des préalables le
sénat n'est pas parti tout seul comme ça
l'aventuré nous sommes évidemment
solidaire d'un certain nombre de
dispositions qui régissent en quelque
sorte les rapports entre
la france l'europe d'un côté la russie
de l'autre mais ce que nous voulions par
ce travail s'est montré que le dialogue
était absolument nécessaire
voyez bien que ce n'est pas toujours
compris par tout le monde c'est un os
que ça veut dire que vous envisagez vous
celle là de travailler à un
rapprochement stratégique avec la russie
je pense effectivement qu'il y à la
nécessité de rapprocher déjà nos
analyses et puis de voir quels sont les
éléments de règlement des différents
conflits sur lesquels la france la
russie membres tous les deux du conseil
de sécurité sont quand même des grandes
puissances peuvent apporter des éléments
constructifs à la paix je vais prendre
un exemple tout de suite dans les sujets
qui manif à 6 h
oui oui les sujets qui fâchent alors
nous trahissons que prenait reprendre du
trend va prendre du crès alors sur le
crâne de deux choses l'une ou bien où on
voit bien que la sphère de l'ukraine est
au coeur des difficultés que rencontre
la russie et l'europe
réciproquement après s'est infligée
mutuellement des sanctions tout ceci est
bien connu il y a sur la fère de
l'ukrainienne il y a eu des désaccords
minsk et les accords minsk une deux qui
normalement devrait permettre de prendre
des initiatives
un certain langue du reste ont été
prises il ya eu récemment des
libérations de prisonniers
ce sont des petits pas on peut imaginer
que tout ça n'a pas d'importance
en fait en a beaucoup et donc ce que
nous devenons nous souhaitons nous
demander à nos amis russes c'est
effectivement que cette politique des
petits pas et des initiatives permettent
de progresser mais nous demandons la
même chose aux ukrainiens lorsque nous
les envoyons nous avons accueilli le
présent les elins ski peu de temps après
son élection nous lui avons dit que
notamment la loi de régionalisation des
provinces de l'est devaient être mises
en oeuvre
elle ne l'est pas et on sait que c'est
une des difficultés que les ré que la
russie met en avant pour expliquer
pourquoi les choses ne progresse pas or
on voit bien que cette affaire d'ukraine
empoisonne la relation entre la russie
et l'europe et le monde occidental mais
un général et donc à ce titre bon nombre
de choses ne progresse pas et par
exemple les le régime des sanctions qui
est un régime que nos sens nos
entreprises nos agriculteurs à notre nom
aux secteurs du luxe de
l'agroalimentaire ont ressenti comme une
dépénalisation très forte
ben on ne peut pas vraiment faire
avancer les choses tant que ce genre de
conflits existent si on pense alors
est-ce que vous pensez que le président
poutine peut changer sa stratégie peut
la faire évoluer peut faire évoluer sa
position là dessus
compte tenu notamment de ses besoins
économies notamment nous le pensons nous
le pensons vraiment d'abord parce que
c'est un président qui conduit la russie
avec les les projets qui sont les siens
la volonté de redevenir la grande
puissance mondiale que le que la russie
a toujours été dans l'histoire
et ceci n'est absolument pas
contradictoire avec les objectifs qui
sont les nôtres mais que l'on peut on a
pris l'exemple de la russie on pourrait
parler aux deux de l'ukraine on pourrait
prendre l'exemple de la syrie on voit
bien que la syrie qui a été finalement
nous avons remis un petit peu les clés
de cette affaire à la russie qui a pris
un rôle beaucoup plus important qu'on
imaginait et bien maintenant plus rien
ne se règlera sur l'avenir de la russie
sans la présence sans la présence de la
russie à la table de négociations donc
plutôt comme certains le préconisent
d'attendre des accords qui ne viennent
jamais nous nous préférons identifié
dire voilà moi je vais prendre un
exemple d'un effort que nous demandons à
la russie je vais en prendre à tout de
suite il figure dans notre
vous le savez la france est très
présente en afrique bien
la russie aussi elle s'y implantent
c'était tout à fait son droit et est là
pour çà ddl utilisent des procédures qui
sont pas toujours les nôtres mais on
sait très bien que danser dans ces pays
et notamment en république démocratique
du congo
il ya des campagnes anti française qui
se développe ça a été aussi le cas au
burkina et ces mémos mali alors que
notre présence n'a rien de
néocolonialistes et les la peau la
sécurité le confort et conforter les
régimes qui sont là et bien nous
demandons à nos amis russes de nous
aider pour ne pas alimenter cette espèce
de sentiment anti-français et que bien
au contraire
la russie nous aident à jouer le rôle
qui est le nôtre à la russie et à nous à
savoir de faire en sorte que ces régimes
se stabilise se renforce
faute de quoi le terrorisme risque de
les embarquer vous n'avez pas de réponse
et vous n'avez pas de moyen de pression
la pub non nous n'avons pas de moyen de
pression nous n'avons que notre bonne
volonté et l'amitié et la volonté
d'avancer ensemble et moi je
reconnaîtrais je reconnais tout à fait
de la part du conseil de la fédération
de sa présidente de mon homologue
constant singles cette chef avec lequel
on fait un travail très positif
il ya cette volonté d'apporter notre
pierre commune moi je ne suis pas le miz
affaires étrangères je ne suis pas au
gouvernement je ne peux pas prendre des
initiatives mais le rôle du parlement
c'est à la fois de contrôler et de
conseiller le gouvernement et à chaque
fois nous disons il faut aller plus vite
il faut aller plus loin dans une
question orale récente que j'ai posées
au gouvernement
j'ai dit il faut moins de diplomatie des
déclarations et un peu plus de
diplomatie de l'action si on revient
monsieur le président maintenant en
conséquence de la crise du coronavirus
sur les rapports de force dans le monde
est ce que vous considérez un peu comme
le président trump que que la chine est
responsable de cette situation et
qu'elle devrait justement supporter une
partie de la responsabilité comment vous
jugez la relation entre la chine et les
états unis à la suite de cette épidémie
qui n'est pas terminée et qui est loin
d'être terminée je pense que tout le
monde comprend que la relation
entre la chine et les états unis
évidemment dépassent très largement
cette affaire de pandémie du coc vide et
que j'allais dire tout ce qui alimente
la querelle pour prendre le leadership
dans le monde est utilisé par les deux
puissances
alors évidemment sous bénéfice
d'inventaire car il faudra encore
travailler longtemps pour comprendre
comment d'un marché à one ou des animaux
sont vendus
cette mise à déferler sur le monde
je pensais évidemment que la chine a une
responsabilité ce n'est pas leur faire
injure que de leur dire on sait très
bien que cette crise est partie de la
chine
ce n'est pas la première fois il ya eu
dans le passé d'autres épidémies qui
sont parties de la chine
et je pense qu'il faudra peut-être aider
ce pays à réfléchir aux moyens d'éviter
que ce genre d'affaires se renouvelle
alors maintenant cette crise du coc vide
est utilisée dans le langage du
président américain comme un argument
supplémentaire pour combattre le rôle de
la chine
nous pensons que tout ça ne sert pas la
paix vous savez la france ne s'inscrit
pas du tout dans cette espèce de déchets
de perroquets des des petites phrases
des tweets qui enflamme et qui moi je
pense que ces grands dirigeants ont le
devoir de travailler au multilatéralisme
de sang tentent de se parler il ya des
intérêts économiques évidents qui
s'entrechoquent
on le sait il ya déficit américain
vis-à-vis du commerce chinois qui est de
l'ordre de 400 milliards de dollars
c'est insupportable et vous le savez
vous-même qui est un grand journaliste
économique vous savez mieux que tout
ceci ne sous-entend pas pour autant
qu'il faut allumer des feux partout les
uns contre les autres qui va sortir
gagnant de cette crise les états unis ou
la chine qui va sortir grandie écoutez
sincèrement au jour d'aujourd'hui je
n'en sais rien parce que je pense que la
chine
à la différence des amis des etats unis
la chine travaille dans le long terme
elle investit dans le long terme du
reste le choix de gouvernance donnant au
président xi jinping la longueur d'un
mandat qu'aucune démocratie ne connaît
permet de bien comprendre le mode de
raisonnement des chinois qui n'a rien à
voir avec le no il s'inscrit dans la
durée et ce qu'ils veulent c'est qu'en
2049 pour le centenaire de la chine
populaire il soit la première puissance
du monde
pour ça nous le constatons par exemple
en matière militaire
est ce qu'on sait par exemple que la
chine mais tous les quatre ans
l'équivalent de toute la marine
nationale française à l'eau tous les
quatre ans la chine met à l'eau des
porte-avions des frégates au hand si
grand nombre que en compte toute la
marine nationale française à avoir bien
on voit bien qu'il ya un projet qui
n'est pas fatalement agressif mais enfin
qui veut dire maintenant la chine est là
elle est en méditerranée
elle est dans l aidant dans le golfe du
bengale et les délais maintenant même au
large de l'amérique latine
ils veulent compter voilà c'est c'est un
jeu de grande puissance
ça ne plaît pas aux américains qui
avaient jusqu'à présent l'impression de
faire la loi mais comme ils disent
régulièrement qui veulent se désengager
les occuper leur place pendant ce temps
là on regarde les tweets passé et les
bals fait changer et on boira et
pointent en général je parle des
européens on aurait pu parler des
européens longuement mais je voudrais
pour terminer vous posez deux ou trois
petites questions très brême
parce qu'on a quand même l'impression
que le monde est très désorganisée et à
des questions jess détenir pragmatique
qu'est ce que vous répondez est ce qu'il
faut par exemple raboter le pouvoir des
entreprises du digital qui prennent de
plus en plus de poids par rapport aux
états ma réponse est oui
ma réponse est oui les entreprises du
digital sont des entreprises extrêmement
performante qui ont apporté des progrès
énormes dans nos rapports entre nous
mais ils ne doivent pas devenir ceux qui
tirent effectivement les systèmes dans
le monde ça c'est très important
faut-il réorganiser le monde est faut-il
réveiller l'om c'est l'organisation
mondiale du commerce par exemple qui
dort jeu
toutes les assemblées qui met en avant
le multilatéralisme les enceintes où on
second dialogue doivent être
effectivement privilégié et cela ne va
pas dans le sens de la dernière décision
du président américain de quitter
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
je pense que tout ça est très mauvais un
car ça ça laisse les très grandes
puissances jouer uniquement sur leurs
seuls intérêts et on a besoin d'un tout
petit peu plus de dialogue et de
compréhension
donc je pense que l'om c'est évidemment
doit être de nouveau réactivé mais là
encore vous voyez bien qu'il s'agit d'un
combat de titans entre la chine et
l'italie
c'est assez compliqué d'influer sur sur
lors des propres décisions
vous disiez en démarrant l'émission que
un des rôles de la france dans le monde
s'était aussi de de protéger les valeurs
de la de la démocratie est ce que c est
ce que vous n'êtes pas pessimiste là
lorsque vous voyez l'évolution du monde
disons que ce que nous voyons sous nos
yeux étaient assez qu'on ne va pas
fatalement dans le bon sens et on voit
que ce sont des régimes j'allais dire
plutôt autoritaire qui tiennent un peu
le haut du pavé comme je l'aï dit au
début de mon propos nos nos démocraties
parlementaires ont un petit peu de mal à
se faire entendre moelleux j'ai reçu une
délégation parlementaire chinois il ya
de ça quelques tentes et qui nous dit
nous à pékin il n'y a pas de gilet jaune
alors évidemment bon et cela fait
réfléchir car c'est un fait y'a pas de
gilet jaune à pékin il ya peut-être
d'autres formes de contestation du reste
mais c'est sûr que il ya un jeu des
grandes puissances j'allais dire assez
autoritaire qui nous qui posons en
j'allais dire qu'ils qui nous incite à
plus d'europe
quelque part ça doit nous inciter à plus
d'europe parce que l'europe elle peut un
jour ne plus exister sur le plan
diplomatique et sur le plan de son
influence et n'être qu'un gigantesque
marché de 500 millions de consommateurs
mais ne plus compter dans la vie
internationale qu'elle était encore bon
merci beaucoup de nous avoir consacré 7
cette demi heure l'émission est terminée
on retrouve cet entretien en rediffusion
sur sur rtl on la retrouve en replay
bien sûr sur le site internet arte
france point tv et puis surtout les
réseaux sociaux merci à vous monsieur le
président merci à tous merci
[Musique]